best-selling author Jack Spencer finally  released a new book today that confirms  his place in the one-hit wonder aisle  we're just going on a grown-up vacation  we used to do it all the time you guys  know all about this place trust are you  a list of double books late  [Applause]  Hey  welcome to Green Acres you like it or  the land  [Music]  we should go you are not staying here  for us you're staying for Magic Mike  hello there oh hello  Tarzan we are supposed to be saving our  marriage but all you have done is be  dude downer  [Music]  this is the free zone  [Music]  you guys have totally made for glamping  glamping is that like a thing totally we  keep doing that  [Music]  you